Donc nous avons commencé à considérer la doctrine sur la chute, les péchés et les châtiments.
Et on a rappelé que ce sixième chapitre est considéré à sa bonne place dans l'ordre,
car on a fait tous les travails d'abord, surtout sur être sûr que la parole de Dieu
est la seule source fiable pour la connaissance de Dieu
et pour la connaissance de quelle manière nous pouvons nous réconcilier avec Dieu.
Ensuite, on a considéré la doctrine sur Dieu et la doctrine sur les œuvres de Dieu.
Et donc c'est l'effet citant de la théologie, c'est-à-dire on a contemplé Dieu
dans la manière la plus explicite que la Bible nous présente, sur ses perfections, sa gloire.
Et c'est important d'avoir considéré ces choses avant qu'on considère la chute,
car ça fait partie, comme on verra, des restes de la corruption du péché.
Ça fait partie de cette condition de rébellion,
la difficulté que nous avons de reconnaître nos fautes
et cette tendance que nous avons d'être victimiste envers nos péchés.
Au lieu de nous responsabiliser du péché, de la rébellion,
au lieu de reconnaître que sommes-nous la cause ultime
de tous les dégâts qu'on a provoqués par notre rébellion,
nous avons une tendance de mettre Dieu en question
pourquoi Dieu est un bon sang, il a pu permettre que ces choses arrivent.
Donc c'est clair que nous avons même une réponse pour ça,
car à l'origine, à l'aidant, on a pu connaître une certaine mesure,
même de l'infinie gloire, grâce des dieux,
mais nous avons connu Dieu en tant que créateur.
Et la gloire de Dieu, la Bible elle-même, nous dit ça clairement.
Dieu a révélé son infinie richesse en termes de grâces
et même de gloire, surtout par la rédemption.
Donc si on reste dans l'état original parfait,
sans que les péchés jamais aient lieu,
même s'il y a beaucoup d'aspects qui restent en mystère pour nous,
la réalité c'est que nous ne pourrions jamais connaître Dieu
comme on peut le connaître aujourd'hui,
dans une mesure des grâces, des gloires,
des compassions, des miséricordes si élevées,
comme si on avait connu à l'origine, à la création.
Et donc, la réalité c'est que dans l'ordre,
on va traiter la chute après avoir traité
cette insistance et cette clarté et cette récourence biblique
qui nous présente Dieu comme sang, comme bon,
comme un Dieu souverain,
aucune chose n'échappe à son contrôle.
Et Dieu lui-même ne peut pas être l'auteur du mal,
il ne peut tenter personne.
Et on s'est mis dans un bon encadrement,
dans un ordre des raisonnements
et dans un ordre des priorités bibliques
pour qu'en arrivant ici, personne n'ose suggérer
qu'il y ait la moindre tâche d'injustice en Dieu.
Ok ?
Donc l'importance de l'ordre.
Et donc pour considérer la chute,
on a fait un rappel
que nous sommes dans un côté,
dans une position un peu plus favorable,
même si c'est très triste,
car c'est l'une des doctrines bibliques
qu'on n'a pas besoin de chercher
à convaincre les personnes de cette réalité.
Donc c'est la doctrine la plus auto-évidente,
la plus explicite.
Personne ne va mettre en question
le fait qu'il y a quelque chose de mauvais
avec l'homme,
car nous sommes toujours en train de chercher
une explication qui n'est pas correcte
quand on ne dépend pas des écritures
et nous sommes toujours en train de chercher
des traitements.
Et donc il y a au moins deux grands diagnostics,
mais ce qu'il y a comment,
c'est qu'il y a une reconnaissance historique
qu'il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas avec lui.
Pour certains,
et donc il y a deux courants principaux
pour essayer d'expliquer la condition de l'homme,
dans la base, dans les fondements,
d'un côté il y a cette notion
des coexistences
entre résistance et progression
où mal et bien,
comme si les mal et les biens étaient coéternels,
ça peut avoir des explications
tout simplement mythiques,
mystiques, religieuses,
ou même des explications
plutôt comportamentales.
Donc c'est juste,
on est devant un constat,
on n'a pas des explications métaphysiques,
mais on voit qu'en surmontant les obstacles,
les crises, les mal,
l'être humain progresse.
Et de l'autre côté,
il y a la théorie de l'évolution.
Donc ce n'est pas la coexistence
du bien et du mal,
c'est plutôt une évolution
et les mal seraient vus
comme nos instants animaux.
Le problème,
c'est que toutes ces théories,
elles sont basées
sur l'observation de l'homme
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui,
comme s'il était aujourd'hui
ce qu'il a toujours été.
Et le problème aussi,
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas la capacité
d'expliquer par ces théories
les crises les plus fondamentales.
On essaie plutôt de supprimer ces crises
par ces explications,
car à nouveau,
si je suis le fruit d'une énergie
qui ne pense pas,
qui a explosé,
il n'y a pas de signification
pour notre crise morale,
pour défendre les droits de l'homme.
Car comment expliquer
la dignité de l'être humain
s'il n'y a pas une base absolue
dans l'existence pour la moralité ?
Comment expliquer
la personnalité de l'homme ?
Donc comment expliquer la coupabilité ?
Comment expliquer ?
Donc voilà,
certains philosophes existentialistes
ont plutôt suggéré
que si ces choses sont liées
au fait qu'on était avant des animaux
et qu'aujourd'hui,
on est devenu un peu plus civil,
il parle des civilités,
mais c'est en saut aussi aveugle,
car ils ne veulent pas parler
des moralités.
On parle des relativismes,
etc.
Et donc,
déjà,
les théories n'expliquent pas
les vraies crises
que tous les êtres m'ont traversent.
Désir d'être infini
en même temps qu'on est fragile,
syndrome de ponique,
etc.
On n'est jamais satisfait
avec l'idée
de dire
comme on entend dans la radio
quand quelqu'un va mourir.
La lumière
de cette personne,
elle était tente
avec cette impersonnalité,
comme si c'était
éteindre la télé.
Et on sait très bien
que ce n'est pas suffisant
pour nous.
Et donc,
la réalité,
c'est que nous ne sommes pas
des énergies.
Je me rappelle très bien
des amis
un peu plus
New Age,
les moments où Mayra
était
au traitement intensif
avec son problème cardiaque.
Et ces amis
qui se disent athées,
etc.,
qui m'envoient des messages
en disant
je t'envoie
des vibrations positives.
Et je me suis dit
heureusement,
je ne peux pas dépendre
des vibrations positives.
Car vibrations positives
ne peuvent rien faire.
Des vibrations non personnelles.
Et c'est un saut
complètement cohérent
avec ce que ces personnes
disent croire.
Et la réalité,
c'est que moi,
j'ai un Père céleste
à qui je peux me diriger,
qui possède
toute la puissance
dans l'univers,
qui a la capacité
de me réconforter,
de me consoler,
même si les pires arrivent,
et qui a aussi
la capacité
d'aider dans la guérison.
Et donc,
ça montre en fait
la catastrophe qui est
et tous ces traitements
très superficiels.
Les traitements
qui vont passer
par la suppression
de la coupabilité
et la coupabilité
va à chaque fois
revenir
et à chaque fois
on s'est reconfronté.
Et voilà pourquoi
nous sommes
la génération
en France
la plus consommatrice
des psychotropes
dans l'histoire.
Et donc,
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
de quelle manière
on essaye
d'échapper
de ces réalités
par la suppression
du raisonnement logique
ou même
du raisonnement
simplement.
Car soit on prend
des médicaments
pour ne plus réfléchir,
soit on essaye
de nier
ce qui est évident
par rapport
à notre propre
sens de moralité.
Et donc,
on a besoin forcément
de la Bible
pour expliquer
qui nous sommes,
ce qui va mal,
pour expliquer
même ses demandes.
Donc,
quand on a considéré
la création
dans son état original,
on a considéré
d'où viennent
ces aspirations
si élevées,
cette noblesse
de l'homme,
désir d'être infini,
désir d'être
à la hauteur
de notre paramètre moral,
de pouvoir vivre
à la hauteur
de nos exigences personnelles,
de pouvoir vivre
une vie d'amour,
une vie louable,
de recevoir
et expérimenter
un amour
qui puisse
véritablement
nous satisfaire,
cette connexion
avec Dieu.
Et donc,
toute cette soif,
toute cette détresse
ne peuvent qu'être
expliquées
par la bonne origine
que la Bible nous présente
et la notion
de discontinuité,
la chute,
qui explique aussi
nos crises
aujourd'hui.
Et donc,
on a divisé
cette étude
sur la chute
en deux grandes parties.
La considération
directe
des textes bibliques
pour qu'on soit
plus capable
à comprendre
les langages
doctrinaires
qu'on va voir
dans la confession de foi.
Car dans la confession de foi,
on a développé
parfois des termes
techniques
qui essayent
de préciser mieux
des conceptions
que la Bible
nous présente,
parfois par des déclarations
directes,
mais parfois
par des narratives.
Et la description
historique,
narrative
de la chute
est une description
qui nous permet
déjà
Dieu
dans sa sagesse,
dans sa condescendance.
Il a été
efficace
à inspirer
l'enregistrement
historique
de la chute
dans un langage
qui a la capacité
de soi-même
de nous équiper
pour comprendre
qu'est-ce qui nous a amenés
à la chute,
quelle est la nature
ou l'essence
du péché
et comment
se donner
la progression
du péché
original,
car
tous ces enseignements
bibliques
vont se reproduire
aussi
dans tout épisode
des tentations
et des chutes
qu'on va vivre
aujourd'hui.
Donc quand on est
en train de contempler
la première chute,
on est en train
de contempler aussi
la progression
du péché.
Là,
nous voyons
l'agence
de Satan
directement
car à l'origine
la tentation
devrait venir
de l'extérieur.
Malheureusement,
nous aujourd'hui,
à cause des restes
de la corruption
du péché,
nous avons des tentations
qui sont produites
par nous-mêmes.
Satan n'a pas besoin
d'être engagé
dans toutes les tentations
qu'on vit.
Nous pouvons être tentés
par nos propres
convatices,
par nos propres désirs,
etc.
Et donc,
même si les débuts
de cette tentation
étaient externes,
la progression
et les tentations
et Satan continue
encore aujourd'hui aussi
de pouvoir
la tentation
pour nous.
Et donc,
c'est très important
pour nous
de faire cet exercice
avec une mentalité
très pratique
pour évaluer
notre propre conduite.
Comment on va
se protéger
de ces situations ?
Et donc,
je vais revenir
sur ça bientôt.
Et donc,
dans l'exposition,
on a fait un rappel
de l'état
de la condition
originale parfaite
pour revenir
aussi
à la conception
que même
ces tests
ou ces pactes
que Dieu a fait
avec ces deux arbres,
l'arbre de la vie,
l'arbre de la connaissance
du bien et du mal,
était aussi
une manière
des dieux,
des pouvoirs,
un moyen
des récompenses
pour que la condition
de l'être humain
qui était déjà
parfaite
soit encore élevée.
Il pourrait
pécher
dans ces pactes
qui avaient été
établis avec Dieu,
mais il pouvait aussi
rendre sa condition
des béatitudes
encore plus amplifiées.
C'est pour ça
qu'on appelle
d'une perfection
séminale.
C'est comme si
c'était une perfection
d'une sémence
qui pourrait encore
se développer,
s'épanouir davantage.
Et donc,
cette élévation
de la relation
de l'être humain
avec Dieu
passe par
cette soumission
volontaire
car nous avions été
créés parfaitement
et nous avons
vécu
jusqu'avant ces pactes,
nous avons vécu,
Adon Yèvre
ont vécu
cette expérience
tout simplement
des libertés
dans la direction
d'un fonctionnement
naturel
et très bénéfique
mais quelque part,
et là j'utilise
les termes
avec beaucoup de tact
car on était
quand même déjà
des êtres humains,
mais presque automatique.
C'est la loi des dieux
naturellement en nous
et nous vivons
pour la gloire des dieux
de manière très naturelle
et Dieu a établi
ces pactes
pour que nous ayons
l'opportunité
d'en plus
de fonctionner
naturellement
en tant qu'obéissant
à la règle des dieux,
à l'ordre
qu'il a créé pour nous,
on a pu
nous soumettre
volontairement
et exprimer
la gloire
de cette soumission
volontaire
que le Seigneur Jésus
en tant qu'enfant des dieux
l'exprime éternellement.
Et donc,
nous pouvions
sortir d'un cadre
des créatures
à l'image
des dieux
à un cadre
des soumissions
volontaires
en progressant
dans notre condition.
Et si on était
approuvé
dans ces thèses,
et voilà pourquoi,
même si on appelle
les pactes
des œuvres,
car Adam et Ève
pourraient,
dans cette époque-là,
encore,
ils avaient
la capacité
de conquérir
leurs récompenses
par leurs œuvres,
vous êtes avec moi,
mais même ces pactes
étaient un pacte
des grâces,
car c'était un pacte
qui les a quittés
dans le lieu
extérieur au jardin
pour les mettre
dans les jardins
et pour leur donner
l'opportunité
de manger
de l'arbre
de la vie.
Ce qui est le plus triste
dans toute cette
question des chutes,
c'est que Satan
réussit à conduire
l'humanité
à être plus tenté
par l'arbre
interdit
que d'être motivé
par l'arbre
de la vie,
de la récompense.
Et donc,
il y avait deux arbres
qu'on ne pouvait pas
encore manger
et on a été plus tenté
pour l'arbre
de la rébellion,
de l'autonomie
que par l'arbre
de la soumission volontaire
qui rendrait
notre condition
encore plus développée,
prospère
et éternelle.
On pourrait
rentrer dans
une condition
où on ne pourrait
pas tomber,
échouer,
rendre éternelle
notre condition
des béatitudes
et encore plus développée.
Mais,
on a plutôt choisi
par cette condition
où nous nous trouvons
aujourd'hui
où nous ne pouvons
ne pas pécher,
nous ne pouvons
ne pas mourir.
C'est la condition
d'esclavage
l'être humain.
Et comment ces choses
se sont passées ?
Donc, d'abord,
la description de la chute,
elle nous enfame beaucoup
car ça décrit
tout épisode des chutes.
ça décrit
dès la racine
de quelle manière
on est marché
vers la désordre.
Et donc,
on a lu les versets
1 à 7
et donc,
je vais juste
vous résumer
quelques éléments
qu'on a considérés
la dernière fois.
Le premier,
c'est que l'élément
de la tentation
était un élément
externe.
Donc,
pour certains théologiens,
c'est l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles
les anges
n'ont pas
des chances
ou d'occasion
pour la rédemption,
c'est car,
dans leur cas,
la tentation
est venue
totalement
de même
de l'intérieur.
Donc,
ça,
c'est une possibilité
mais ce n'est pas
une nécessité.
Mais,
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
avec tous les mystères
qui restent
car on ne sait pas
comment
ou à quel moment
la tentation externe
déviant
la conception
d'un péché
interne
car la Bible
elle-même décrit
que même si
la consommation
a été avec
les manger du fruit,
ok,
on sait très bien
que tout commence
dans le cœur,
la convoitise,
les désirs
et ensuite
la consommation externe.
Et donc,
que personne
lorsqu'il est tenté
ne dise
c'est Dieu
qui m'étante
car Dieu ne peut
être tenté
par les mâles
et il n'étante
lui-même personne.
Mais chacun
est tenté
quand il est attiré
et amorcé
par sa propre convoitise
puis la convoitise
lorsqu'elle a conçu
enfante les péchés
et les péchés
étant consommés
produits
la mort.
Et donc,
ça c'est la description
qui semble avoir
en elle-même
en tête,
ok,
l'épisode
de la chute originale,
ok,
même si
c'est Jacques
qui va décrire
dans le Nouveau Testament.
Et donc,
on voit
beaucoup
des
voilà,
d'exemples
par rapport
à cette progression
que je viens de résumer
par les verset cités
ici.
Et donc,
l'origine
du péché
a un aspect
des mystères
car l'homme,
il était parfait,
la femme,
elle était parfaite,
mais nous voyons
comment ces choses
se développent
et que cela ne vient
pas des dieux
et cela ne vient
pas de l'homme
lui-même
au départ.
À un moment donné,
ça se transforme,
donc même si la tentation
vient de l'extérieur,
l'homme n'est pas
excusable
car il devrait
résister
à cette tentation.
Il pouvait
résister
à cette tentation.
donc,
on a considéré
aussi
que Satan
il agit
avec beaucoup
de subtilités
et donc la tentation
pour nous
qu'elle vienne
de Satan
ou non,
elle vient toujours
avec beaucoup
de subtilités.
Au départ,
il vient avec
apparence d'innocence,
c'est-à-dire
c'était un serpent
littéral
que Satan
a fait
aux âges
pour se communiquer
avec Ève
et donc
dans ses stratégies
subtiles,
il vient attaquer
d'abord la femme
que possiblement
Satan aime bien
saisir toutes
les occasions
stratégiques
qu'il puisse avoir.
Donc,
comme Adam,
c'était lui
qui était
les représentants
chefs
et lui qui avait
écouté lui-même
audiblement
les commandements
de la part des dieux
et donc c'est lui
qui serait peut-être
les moins
susceptibles
à la chute.
Ok ?
Et donc là,
on voit comment
Satan va venir
avec l'apparence
d'innocence
avec ces termes
qu'on a considérés
nus
car les serpents
lui-même
étaient
les plus nus
et là,
on traduit par ruser
car c'est
ces doubles sens-là
mais c'est une apparence
d'innocence.
Déjà,
un animal créé par Dieu,
apparence d'innocence,
aujourd'hui,
c'est complètement différent
pour nous
car il y a eu
même un changement
dans la nature
du serpent
comme on voit
après la chute.
Mais bon,
à partir de ces moments-là,
ça vient de l'extérieur
et c'est par un serpent
littéral
qui a une apparence
d'innocence
et qui commence
à suggérer
quelque chose
qui pourrait être considéré
comme bénéfique
pour Ève.
En même temps,
cette subtilité
se transforme
à s'aimer
les doutes
et donc
en s'aimant
les doutes
avec
quelques distorsions
qui veulent mettre
en question
les caractères
des dieux
et la parole
des dieux.
Dieu a dit
lorsqu'il a établi
les pactes
qu'il avait
pourvu
généreusement
tous les arbres
pour qu'ils puissent
manger
à l'exception
d'un arbre.
Donc,
l'emphase
des dieux,
c'est totale générosité
et tous les fruits
étaient beaux à la vue.
La Bible
est décrite
de la même manière.
Il n'y avait rien
des spéciales
dans les visuels
de cet arbre interdit
à part l'interdition
et la tentation
que Satan a ajouté.
Et donc,
à partir de là,
on voit
que la question
posée par Satan
est déjà
en train
de détériorer
cette conception
d'un dieu
qui est bon,
qui est généreux.
C'est plutôt
un dieu des privations.
Dieu ne vous permet pas
de manger tous les fruits
du jardin.
C'est plutôt comme ça
qu'il pose la question.
Quelle est la réponse d'Eve ?
Et donc,
il faut qu'on regarde
à chaque fois
notre mentalité
quand on voit
nos situations
aujourd'hui,
nos circonstances.
Et des fois,
on fait usage
des circonstances
difficiles qu'on traverse
pour justifier
combien on va devenir
relâché
dans notre vie spirituelle,
dans notre discipline spirituelle.
Mais il n'y a
aucune excuse pour nous.
Dieu est infiniment
plus généreux
qu'il y a les petites
difficultés qu'on traverse.
Et donc,
subtilité,
c'est mettre les doutes
aux bonnes intentions
des dieux,
les caractères des dieux.
Est-ce que Dieu est vrai ?
Est-ce que Dieu est généreux ?
Ou est-ce qu'il est
un tyran capricieux ?
Et donc ensuite,
quand on considère
la progression du péché
par la réponse
de la femme,
on voit que ça commence
par l'érosion
de la confiance
dans la parole
des dieux
et dans l'autorité
instituée par Dieu.
Qui donne
les instructions
fiables ?
Qui cette femme
connaît plus ?
Et qui sont les autorités
instituées sur sa vie ?
À qui elle doit écouter ?
Et au lieu d'écouter
plutôt son mari ?
Au lieu de faire confiance
à ce qui Dieu a dit
à son mari ?
Car dans la virée
de chaque jour,
Dieu venait les rencontrer.
Et donc,
cette femme a donné
plus de crédit
à un étrange,
trahison,
et donc,
c'est une méfiance.
Donc,
à la racine
de tous les péchés,
on va retrouver,
les péchés définis
comme manque de foi.
N'est pas croire
à la parole de Dieu.
à Dieu comme fiable.
N'est pas croire
à Dieu comme bon.
Et tous les péchés
sont dans cette direction.
Et donc,
à partir de là,
on pourrait imaginer
Dieu tarde
à nous permettre
de manger les fruits
de la vie.
Dieu tarde
à m'apporter
cette bénédiction.
Est-ce qu'il est
véritablement pour moi ?
Est-ce que je ne dois
pas faire autrement ?
Vous comprenez ?
C'est de la même manière
qu'on raisonne
encore aujourd'hui.
Donc,
l'origine du péché
commence par
cette érosion
de la confiance
et cela se manifeste
par la manière
dont on commence
à céder
aux tentations
de Satan
car la réponse
de la femme,
elle va réduire
ce que Dieu avait dit
dans le sens
où au lieu
de répéter
la générosité
de Dieu,
elle va dire
au verset
2 et 3,
donc verset 2,
la femme répond
à Dieu serpent,
nous mangeons
du fruit
des arbres
du jardin
mais quant au fruit
de l'arbre
qui est au milieu
du jardin,
Dieu a dit
vous ne mangerez
point
et vous
n'y toucherez
point.
Donc,
quant au fruit
de l'arbre,
pardon,
nous mangeons
du fruit
des arbres,
ce n'est pas
on mange
tous les fruits
de tous les arbres,
réduction,
et ensuite,
n'est pas
ou n'est point
touché,
ce que Dieu
n'a pas rajouté.
Donc,
elle est déjà
en progression
de voir Dieu
comme un tyran,
comme un Dieu,
des privations
au lieu d'être
un Dieu généreux.
Et donc,
à partir de là,
quand Satan voit
la moindre
baisse des gardes,
si on va céder un petit peu,
il va grandir.
Et donc là,
il passe de sa subtilité
à l'attaque
plus osée
en faisant des déclarations
audaces
pour lesquelles
il ne pourra
jamais
accomplir.
Donc,
il va dire
certainement,
n'est-ce pas,
les serpents
disent à la femme
et donc,
il y a aussi
dans la réponse
de la femme
les doutes,
des peurs
que vous ne mouriez,
sauf que Dieu
avait dit
certainement
vous mouriez
et donc là,
Satan voit
qu'il y a les doutes
dans le cœur
de la femme
et les serpents
disent
vous ne mourrez point,
certainement
vous n'allez pas mourir.
mais Dieu sait
qu'il commence
à mettre des paroles
dans la bouche
des dieux.
Les jours
où vous mangerez,
vos yeux s'ouvriront
et que vous serez
comme des dieux
connaissant les bien
et les mal.
Donc là,
il passe
à un attaque
très osée
pour saisir
cette vulnérabilité
en faisant
des affirmations
très audacieuses
et non seulement
il va attaquer
par des déclarations
certaines,
donc les doutes
deviennent
en conviction
opposée
à la parole
des dieux,
ok,
et ensuite
il offre
les grandes tentations,
les grandes motivations
vers les péchés
et ce sont les grandes tentations
pour nous encore aujourd'hui
qu'il lui-même
Satan a vécues.
Qu'est-ce qu'il va offrir
comme tentation ?
Vous serez comme Dieu,
vous connaisserez
les biens et les mal
et donc c'est quelque part
vous allez arriver,
attention,
à une position
et à une condition
plus élevée
que celle
que vous avez aujourd'hui.
Qu'est-ce qu'il est en train
de faire ?
Il est en train
de promettre
presque la même chose
que Dieu a promis
sauf
qui est par un raccourci
et on sait très bien
que les raccourcis
déjà ne nous amènent jamais
à la bénédiction des dieux
et si nous sommes
enfants des dieux
ça nous pousse plutôt
à une période
plus longue
des corrections,
des disciplines
et ça rétarde
davantage encore
la progression
de nos vies,
la bénédiction attendue.
Et donc à chaque fois
les péchés
il est aussi
une proposition
la tentation
est une proposition
des raccourcis
envers la gloire,
envers les biens
quelque part
qu'on pense être
un bien pour nous.
Et donc lui
il propose
ces tentations
et
c'est là
il nous démontre
de quelle manière
il progresse
dans cette manière
érosée
de péché.
Et donc
qu'est-ce qu'on va
retrouver
à l'origine
du péché aussi
donc dans
ces péchés
originales
on va considérer
donc non seulement
l'érosion
de la confiance
mais aussi
l'omission
des responsabilités.
Donc la femme
qui n'est pas
en train de se soumettre
à ce qu'elle avait
reçu
des autorités
qu'elle avait
dans sa vie
Dieu et son mari
ceux qui étaient
ceux qui méritaient
les plus sa confiance
mais elle-même
va continuer
dans cette démarche.
Et l'homme
comme la Bible
le montrera
à la fin
de ses passages
était tous les temps
de son côté
et il n'a pas
accompli son rôle.
Donc quels étaient
les risques
pour l'homme
aussi ?
C'était peut-être
la peur
de ne pas
confronter
et ça c'est intéressant
car quand on arrivera
à la rédemption
ou à la foi
qui est exprimée
vers la fin du passage
on va voir
que l'homme
a changé
les noms
d'Ève
ou des femmes
pardon
des femmes
à Ève
des
Isha
Homme
Femme
à Mère
et quelque part
leur mission ensemble
c'était de multiplier
et donc ils avaient
une mission ensemble
mais l'homme
il était
en train de recevoir
une grande bénédiction
quand il a constaté
qu'il était seul
qu'il n'était pas complet
Dieu lui donne
la femme
et donc peut-être
qu'ici
la manière
dont la femme
devient
un moyen
des tentations
pour lui
peut démontrer aussi
qu'il avait placé
la femme
dans un endroit
dans son cœur
qui était peut-être
plus élevé
qu'elle ne devrait avoir
vous comprenez ?
Au lieu de se soumettre
à Dieu
de protéger la femme
de sa propre démarche
de sa propre tentation
c'est possible
que cette
ces risques
d'idolatrie
envers la femme
soit là aussi
et donc à ce moment-là
on voit comment
l'homme est omis
la femme
elle prend l'avance
et il y a
cette inversion
de l'ordre
créé par Dieu
l'ordre de la relation
entre Dieu
et l'humanité
et l'ordre de la relation
entre l'homme
et la femme
et l'ordre de la nature
de comment la femme
devrait fonctionner
de comment l'homme
et cet impact
dans toutes les relations
et il y a aussi
donc vers la consommation
effective
cette sensualité animale
donc elle a vu
que les fruits
étaient beaux
aux yeux
agréables
à manger
et à nouveau
tout ce que
tous les autres fruits
avaient aussi
mais l'interdition
a rendu la tentation
peut-être
en visuel
encore plus fort
vers cette chose
mais c'est comme
ce passage
qui le dit aussi
nous sommes attirés
parfois par la partie
la moins noble
au lieu de laisser
l'image des dieux
dans son expression maximale
ce n'est pas pour dire
que les corps
ou les sensations
sont mauvaises
mais c'est pour
savoir et connaître
que nous devrions
gouverner
nos appétits
physiologiques
en soumission
toujours
à ce qu'on sait
être plus élevé
moral
noble
donc les corps
ils devraient être
un glorieux
véhicule
de l'expression
de l'âme
de la gloire
de Dieu
ok
et donc
c'est à travers
les corps
que la gloire
rayonne par nos actions
mais malheureusement
ici
la sensualité
a pris
l'avance
et donc là
c'est intéressant
car quand on verra
les langages
de la chute
des conséquences
on revient à la poussière
c'est comme si Dieu
était en train de dire
vous aviez
manifesté plus tôt
votre comportement
les plus insignifiants
par ces véhicules
glorieux
que j'ai pris
de la terre
pour faire de vous
mon image
et donc
l'ambition idolâtre
qui est là aussi
donc
en voyant
que ça pourrait
lui donner
de la connaissance
c'est ce qu'il est
axé
il dit
qu'il était précieux
pour ouvrir l'intelligence
il prit les fruits
en mangea
donna à son mari
qui était
auprès d'elle
et il en mangea
donc cette inversion
de l'ordre
et donc
on voit
ses conséquences
immédiates
donc là
on voit plus ou moins
de quelle manière
on peut commencer
à identifier
quelle est la nature
du péché
en considérant
les péchés
originales
car on va
s'approcher
dans les prochaines leçons
des définitions
des termes
par rapport
à ce qui est
le péché
mais pour l'instant
dans l'essence
du péché
évident
dans les passages
c'est une sorte
de méfiance
c'est la normalité
c'est de ne pas marcher
selon la norme
que Dieu avait créée
c'est une injustice
une transgression
car c'est de s'opposer
à la parole
des dieux déclarés
c'est un mensonge
car on va
dans la direction
dans l'espoir
que quelque chose
de bien se passe
avec nous
mais ça finit toujours
par la dégradation
c'est maléfique
et mortel
c'est même un type
de suicide
quelque part
chaque péché
qu'on va commettre
c'est ce qui se passe
avec eux
de manière littérale
c'est de l'impiété
car c'est vraiment
des données
plus d'importance
et des valeurs
à l'intimité
avec un étrange
ou avec nous-mêmes
qui est envers Dieu lui-même
la piété
c'est vraiment
cette connexion avec Dieu
et donc les péchés
sont toujours de l'impiété
c'est un mépris
envers Dieu
et sa communion
c'est la fausse liberté
car on pense
être en train d'aller
dans la direction
de l'autonomie
mais on va plutôt
dans la direction
de l'esclavage
et de l'autodestruction
et c'est tout simplement
la désordre
car on devrait
plutôt respecter
cet ordre créé par Dieu
à l'origine
et en ayant un peu
organisé
nos pensées
à cet égard
on va considérer
les résultats
de la chute
mais avant de passer
au résultat de la chute
juste pour qu'on puisse
faire un exercice intéressant
c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
comment la tentation
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
a été aussi
une tentation
très similaire
à la chute originale
et donc pourquoi
cela est important
pour nous
pour deux raisons principales
la première
c'est pour renforcer
la conviction
que Genèse 3
est histoire
littérale
car les similarités
sont telles
que nous ne pourrions
jamais
avoir l'espoir
que la rédemption
du Christ
soit efficace
pour nous
si Christ
n'était pas
en train
de renverser
littéralement
cet épisode
des chutes
par un épisode
d'approbation
et des qualifications
par cette étape
et donc
si on vient ensemble
à Matthieu chapitre 3
j'aimerais vous présenter
!
quelques points très intéressants
remarquer
donc déjà
on commence avec
les versets 16
dès que j'ai dit
j'ai dit
!
celui-ci
est mon fils
bien-aimé
en qui j'ai mis
toute mon affection
donc
quelle est l'importance
du baptême
pour Christ
donc
les baptêmes
des gens baptistes
particulièrement
avaient pour but
la proclamation
publique
c'était une espèce
de
conviction
des péchés
ou confession
publiques
c'est-à-dire
moi
j'ai besoin
d'un nettoyage
d'un lavage
c'était
les baptêmes
des répentances
ok
c'est pas
les mêmes baptêmes
que nous avons
aujourd'hui
donc
quelle est l'essence
pour que Christ
les saints
les fils des dieux
se fasse baptiser
donc
il n'était pas
en train de faire
une confession publique
des péchés
n'est-ce pas
et il avait
vécu
une vie parfaite
donc
il devrait vivre
toute sa vie
avec la capacité
de représenter
tous ceux
qui seront sauvés
par lui
nous
on commet
le péché
dès l'enfance
donc il fallait
que Christ
traverse
une enfance
parfaite
ok
il fallait
qu'il vive
son adolescence
parfaitement
qu'il vive
sa jeunesse
parfaitement
et donc
dans un certain
sens
il devrait
naître
d'une femme
pour nous
représenter
naître
sous la loi
et il devrait
être fils
des dieux
pour pouvoir
être né
d'une vierge
sans la contamination
de péché
en ayant
un corps
réel
humain
avec l'apparence
de la dégradation
de péché
toutefois
sans péché
ok
et donc
les seigneurs
Jésus-Christ
étaient vrais hommes
vrais dieux
par nécessité
des qualifications
pour qu'il puisse
n'est pas
péché
être esclave
de péché
de sa naissance
mais
il devrait
aussi
par nécessité
en tant
qu'il substitut
vivre
cette vie
parfaite
donc il y a
ce qu'on appelle
une obéissance
positive
du Christ
et pour qu'il puisse
nous créditer
son obéissance
il faut qu'il
vit l'obéissance
pendant tous les temps
ok
et donc
dans sa vie privée
il arrive
à ces moments
des baptêmes
et c'est à partir
de là
qu'il commence
les ministères
publics du Christ
donc les baptêmes
du Christ
c'était un baptême
substitutif
c'était comme si
Christ dans les temps
et dans l'espace
il était en train
de prendre sur lui
sur son dos
car c'était
là les ministères
de Jean-Baptiste
préparaient les chemins
pour les messies
pour les libérateurs
et donc les Christ
lorsqu'il vient
se baptiser
Jean-Baptiste
va dire
non
et donc il dit
qu'il n'est pas
digne
même pas
de toucher
à ses standards
et à partir de là
Jésus insiste
il est baptisé
et pourquoi
Jésus devrait être baptisé
car c'est à partir
de ce moment
qu'il inaugure
son ministère
public
c'est à dire
maintenant
il doit accomplir
quelques étapes
de libération
qui sont
nécessaires
en tant
que représentant
c'est à partir
de là
où il va
assumer
officiellement
le fait
qu'il est
la tête
de son église
de son peuple
c'est à partir
de là
qu'il est sur
son dos
vient le poids
de nos péchés
et donc à partir
du moment
où il est baptisé
par Jean-Baptiste
il y a
cette
onction
visible
qui caractérisait
tous les types
messianiques
de l'Ancien Testament
l'onction
les Saint-Esprit
qui venaient
reposaient sur lui
et même si Christ
n'a jamais perdu
sa double nature
en tant que Dieu
dans un mystère
qui nous échappe
l'explication
ou la compréhension
il devrait accomplir
en tant qu'être humain
ce qu'il devrait
accomplir pour nous
avec l'aide
de l'onction
du Saint-Esprit
mais en tant qu'être humain
et donc ce que Christ
est en train de faire
c'est de porter
sur son dos
et d'ici
c'est comme s'il était
en train de dire
d'ici je vais jusqu'à la fin
je vais accomplir
la mission
que j'ai reçue
de mon Père
ok
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
à ce moment
et la difficulté
pour ceux
qui ne veulent pas
voir les serpents
comme littéral
je ne sais pas
comment ils arrivent
à accepter
comme ils doivent
le faire
la manifestation
du Saint-Esprit
en forme de colombe
car c'est comme si
on était en train
de voir
véritablement
une colombe
qui descendait
sur le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
mais plus que ça
le Seigneur Jésus
est
lui-même
Dieu
en forme d'homme
donc à partir
du moment
où on doit
obligatoirement
assumer
ces miracles
sans lesquels
on ne peut pas être sauvé
si on ne croit pas
ces choses
il n'y a aucun empêchement
aucune difficulté
qu'on puisse avoir
pour ces autres passages
et la réalité
c'est que
les colombes
il est là aussi
comme un élément
très important
et très intéressant
des contrastes
avec les serpents
car si les serpents
donnent l'apparence
d'innocence
étant rusé
les colombes
il est véritablement
les symboles
par excellence
d'innocence
dans la Bible
et quand est-ce
que ces symboles
vont apparaître
par exemple
donc il y a
dans les sacrifices
pour représenter
vraiment son innocence
mais particulièrement
je pense que
le passage
le plus important
c'est
c'est avec quoi
les baptêmes
sont comparés
si les baptêmes
et quelque part
les déversements
de la colère des dieux
en Christ
qui a plongé
à notre place
dans la colère des dieux
pour ressusciter
pour repérer
ces vrais lavages
c'est les déluges
notamment
les moments
où la colombe
va apparaître
après les déluges
pour représenter
cette rédemption
cette innocence
cette pacification
que Dieu avait fait
Dieu avait apaisé
pour un temps
avec cet arc-en-ciel
comme symbole
Dieu avait apaisé
pour un instant
pour un certain temps
sa colère
envers l'humanité
et Christ vient
avec cette mission
des paix
des pacifications
donc la colombe
pourrait présenter
la vraie innocence
et la mission
des réconciliations
et donc
il est baptisé
et les pères
et c'est à chaque fois
que Christ est en train
d'affranchir
une étape
très importante
et très difficile
pour accomplir
en tant que substitut
notre salut
que les pères
vont faire cette déclaration
il est fait ici
et il est fait
à la montagne
de la Transfiguration
au veille
de la crucifixion
du Christ
vous êtes avec moi
et qu'est-ce que
le texte va nous dire
donc une fois
que Christ est baptisé
les Saints Esprits
des saints
pour montrer
les sceaux
de sa mission formelle
et les pères
vont lui fortifier
va lui fortifier
par cette déclaration
voici mon fils
bien-aimé
en qui j'ai mis
toute mon affection
donc les plaisirs
du père
étant extrapolé
augmenté
Dieu qui n'arrive pas
à tenir
cette manifestation
d'amour
car les fils
vont faire
quelque chose
d'inédite
d'extraordinaire
il va traverser
la mort
pour nous
ok
ensuite
chapitre 4
verset 1
alors
Jésus fut
conduit par l'esprit
dans les déserts
pourquoi
pour être tenté
par les diables
donc
qui conduit
Jésus
au désert
c'est lui
qui a
oué
les Christ
pour cette mission
vous êtes avec moi
la tentation du Christ
est une étape
nécessaire
formelle
des qualifications
messianiques
pour que Christ
puisse substituer
quelque chose
en tant que représentant
de notre race
qu'on n'a pas
réussi à accomplir
!
il doit faire preuve
d'une soumission
volontaire
malgré la tentation
il doit être
l'Adam
parfait
là où Adam
a échoué
les Christ
il doit accomplir
parfaitement
et la question
principale
c'est
la décision
résolue
et volontaire
malgré
toutes les tentations
d'être un vrai
enfant des dieux
de nous élever
à la position
d'enfant des dieux
par une soumission
volontaire
absolue
à la volonté
du Père
à la parole
à la loi
du Père
et c'est notamment
là où va se jouer
les tentations
de Satan
avec Christ
il sera
subtil encore
mais encore
plus explicite
là il n'est pas
en train de se déguiser
en serpent
il vient
tel qu'il est
pour tenter
des Christ
et donc on voit
de manière
très intéressante
un contraste
entre les circonstances
si Adam
et Ève
étaient
dans la
béatitude
de la
réjouissance
de toute la
prospérité
du jardin des dents
avec tous les fruits
à manger
les Christ
il était en train
d'être tenté
pendant ces 40 jours
qu'il était
en train
de jeûner
et plus
intensifier
encore vers la fin
de cette tentation
là où il avait
encore plus
faim et soif
il a eu faim
il a eu soif
il était
un vrai être humain
et il a été
tenté
dans des circonstances
extrêmement
opposées
et extrêmement
défavorables
les désirs
plus intensifiés
lui il n'avait pas
une épouse
de son côté
il était
dans la solitude
au désert
et Satan
s'est manifesté
explicitement
vers lui
quelle était
la subtilité
de Satan
les parallèles
entre les tentations
d'abord
Satan
de manière très similaire
il va évoquer légèrement
les promesses
des dieux
afin de conduire
un doute
sur les caractères
des dieux
et sur la parole
quelle est
la dernière
parole des dieux
qui Christ
venait d'entendre
on vient de lire
hein
en autre voix
quelle est
la première
déclaration
de Satan
et les tentateurs
s'approcha
vers ces trois
et lui dit
si tu es
fils des dieux
pour s'aimer
les doutes
le Saint-Esprit
n'est jamais
à l'origine
de ce type
de doute
dans les cœurs
dans le vrai croyant
si tu es
le fils des dieux
ordonne
que ces pierres
deviennent
des pains
et donc
si tu es
vraiment
les fils des dieux
comment
Dieu pourrait
te laisser
traverser
ces types
de privations
donc
si tu es
les fils des dieux
rien ne t'empêcherait
à transformer
ces pierres
en pains
et Jésus répondit
il est écrit
l'homme
ne vivra
pas des pains
seulement
mais des toutes
paroles
qui sortent
de la bouche
des dieux
donc comparaison
les fruits
étaient
agréables
à la vue
bons
à manger
imaginez-vous
Christ
avec sa faim
avec la proposition
de pouvoir manger
des pains
ok
et au lieu
de choisir
la tentation
de manger
il va choisir
la parole
des dieux
à l'inverse
de ce qui était
la chute
originale
et donc
la réponse
du Christ
est la bonne
interprétation
avec précision
biblique
car ici
Satan
est en train
de tordre
cette promesse
des dieux
c'est dans
les contextes
où
faire
ces types
des choses
qui Jésus
aurait pu faire
représenterait
échouer
dans sa mission
et dans son obéissance
donc
au lieu de satisfaire
les désirs immédiats
de corps
il préfère
se nourrir
de la parole
des dieux
et donc
il voit
l'ensemble
des écritures
ensuite
Satan
va mal placer
les vraies
écritures
la parole
des dieux
donc alors
les diables
les transporta
dans la ville
sainte
les plaça
sur les hauts
du temple
et lui dit
si tu es fils
des dieux
jette-toi
en bas
car il a t'écrit
il donnera
pour toi
des ordres
à ses anges
et ils te porteront
sur l'aimant
des peurs que ton pied
ne heurtre
contre une pierre
Jésus lui dit
il a été écrit aussi
tu ne tenteras
point
les seigneurs
ton dieu
donc comment organiser
nos vies
n'est pas
tenter
les seigneurs
dans quel sens
quand on voit
la promesse donnée
dans l'Epsomme 81
par rapport aux anges
ce sont des promesses
dirigées à ceux
qui sont en train
d'obéir les seigneurs
et si ce n'est pas
un cadre d'obéissance
donc il y a des nuances
importantes ici
pourquoi
les pinacles du temple
donc peut-être
que la distance
pourrait suggérer
que les anges
viendraient
en train de voler
mais il y avait
beaucoup de suggestions
dans tout ça
dans la conscience
des satans et du Christ
et tout ce que Christ
devrait traverser
et accomplir
en tant
qui est notre
agneau des dieux
qui hôte les péchés
du monde
donc tout ce qui s'est
passé dans les temples
tous les sacrifices
comptaient envers
les sacrifices
qu'il est Christ
et vrai
souffrir
et à nouveau
la notion
du raccourci
elle est là
donc pourquoi
traverser
toute cette souffrance
si les anges
pourraient être là
immédiatement
pour te servir
ok
donc
de théorème
donc Jésus va
confronter un passage
de la Bible
avec un autre passage
et donc la Bible
n'a jamais
des contradictions
mais cette
complémentarité
biblique
nous aide
à savoir
que les promesses
ne fonctionnent pas
de manière aveugle
il faut savoir
dans quel contexte
les choses s'appliquent
et donc ici Jésus
il sait
qu'il ne va pas
subir cette tentation
c'était la même tentation
qu'Adam et Ève
ont fait face
certainement
vous n'allez pas mourir
n'est-ce pas
certainement
vous n'allez pas mourir
vous serez comme Dieu
n'est-ce pas
et là on voit à nouveau
une tentation
envers le suicide
envers la mort
ça ne va pas faire
si tant de mal
ok
et ensuite
on voit
cette opposition
plus audace
avec
une promesse
encore plus
explicite
d'une gloire
raccourcie
ensuite
le diable
les transporta
sur un montagne
très élevé
lui montra
tous les rois
hommes du monde
et leur gloire
et lui dit
je te donnerai
toutes ces choses
si tu te prosternes
et m'adores
donc quelque part
à nouveau
suivre
la parole
de Satan
qui est l'opposé
de la parole
de Dieu
c'est d'adorer Satan
c'est l'idolâtrie
c'est de mettre
Satan
à la position
de Dieu
c'est ce qu'ont fait
nos parents
à l'origine
la première chute
et ça c'est vraiment
pour les mondres péchés
qu'on commet
car chaque péché
c'est comme si on était
en train de dire
c'est plus Dieu
qui me donnerait
les règles
les conseils
maintenant c'est Satan
qui va le faire
on va frapper
à la porte
de Satan
pour chercher
l'aide des dieux
parfois
et la réalité
c'est que
tous les péchés
les moindres péchés
c'est de mettre
Satan
à la place des dieux
c'est de nous mettre
c'est l'idolâtrie
et donc ici
il dit
juste
plie les genus
pour un second
on est seul
personne ne verra
mais la réalité
c'est que
la promesse
que Satan
est en train de faire
à Jésus
c'est un raccourci
envers
les mêmes promesses
que Dieu a fait à Christ
à travers
sa croix
quelles sont les promesses
tous les rois
du monde
toute autorité
toutes les nations
demande à moi
je te donnerai
les nations
pour héritage
c'est cette mission
du Christ
les rois des rois
il vient
pour inaugurer
un peuple
un royaume
des rachetés
sauf que
pour accomplir
la volonté
des dieux
à cet égard
le Seigneur Jésus
doit
accomplir parfaitement
toutes les étapes
de notre rédemption
l'étape
de la tentation
d'une vie
parfaite
d'obéissance
mais non seulement
être capable
de nous créditer
son obéissance
mais il doit
aussi
souffrir
dans sa peau
la punition
qu'on méritait
et donc il y a encore
la croix
qui l'attend
et quand il arrivera
à la croix
la qualière
de Dieu
sera déversée
sur lui
car Dieu
va les traiter
comme s'il était
nous
pour qu'il puisse
nous traiter
comme si on était
Christ
et donc
la croix
est une étape
nécessaire
à travers
laquelle
Christ
va recevoir
cette récompense
qu'est-ce que ça
t'en fait
accourci
je te donne
toute la gloire
de tous les rois
du monde
si tu plies
ton genou
devant moi
et donc il a
cette domination
parasitaire
de ces mondes
il est les dieux
de ces siècles
pas par droit
et ça c'est très
important
c'est car Dieu
afin de développer
une possibilité
de rédemption
pour l'humanité
il a dû
pour une question
de justice
retarder
la punition
de Satan
vous êtes avec moi
ça serait
injuste
quelque part
la part des dieux
de lancer
Satan
immédiatement
à l'enfer
qui a été créé
pour lui
s'il va laisser
du temps
pour que l'humanité
aille la récompense
et donc Dieu
a étendu
cette patience
envers l'humanité
et Satan
a pu profiter aussi
en attendant
les jours
de jugement final
et pendant cette période
Satan
il a énormément
progressé
dans sa domination
des empires
dans la domination
et son influence
dans les mondes
dans les sociétés
dans les individus
la Bible est décrite
comme les dieux
de ces siècles
par contre
c'est à partir
de ces moments-ci
à partir du moment
où Christ
en tant que représentant
de l'humanité
vient
et qu'il résiste
à la tentation
de Satan
que nous allons voir
à partir de maintenant
l'autorité du Christ
manifester
contre les démons
si vous regardez bien
les rythmes
du Nouveau Testament
dans chaque synoptique
dans chaque évangile
vous allez voir
que Dieu
ou Christ
avait déjà manifesté
sa puissance
sur la nature
quelques guérisons
mais à partir
de maintenant
chassement des démons
et donc c'est intéressant
il va être
qualifié
dans cette étape
importante
pour notre salut
il va accomplir
cette étape
à notre place
et donc
quels sont les résultats
les versets 11
alors
les diables
donc il va répondre
à la dernière tentation
Jésus lui dit
retire-toi
Satan
car il a été écrit
tu adoreras
les seigneurs
ton Dieu
et tu les serviras
lui seul
donc il fait
les choix
malgré les difficultés
et les conséquences
d'adorer seulement Dieu
c'est là
où on a échoué aussi
dans la première tentation
et donc
les choix d'approbation divine
et les conséquences
verset 11
alors les diables
laissa
et voici des anges
vant reprès de Jésus
et les servaient
et donc là
la promesse
est accomplie
là
il a accompli
la tentation
il a honoré Dieu
par son obéissance
et là
il reçoit
les premiers signes
de sa qualification
les anges viennent
et servent Jésus
et ça
c'est un indice
très clair
de cet
accomplissement
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
et donc ici
nous sommes devant
une grande étape
accomplie
l'obéissance
du Christ
la résistance
qui l'a qualifiée
en tant que
notre représentant
et bien sûr
ce qui va
l'atteindre
à partir de là
c'est la croix
ok
donc Jésus
il était clairement
en train de renverser
à nouveau
de manière historique
l'épisode historique
de la chute
et vous voyez comment
c'est important pour nous
de considérer ces choses
de la chute